Adams with us in Houston Texas hey Adam
how are you I'm actually scared right
now how you doing Dave better than I
deserve what are you scared of well my
wife and I are talking about having a
second child and I don't know if it's
the right time with where we are in our
depth snowball are you working on
getting out of debt well we are working
as hard as we can yes how much debt do
you have about fifty three thousand
dollars correct and you make what kind
of household income just under 105 good
and what kind of debt is the 53 one car
credit cards and medical how much is out
on the car 16 okay and how much debt
have you paid off so far and we've paid
off about seven along the vet tech about
four months okay so in two years you
would be debt-free at the current rate
mm-hmm okay and what does that mean you
can't have a baby
we both suffer from quite expensive
medical and it just scares me even
during the pregnancy you both suffer
from quite extensive medical you've got
medical issues correct health issues
okay yes and that affects her her
carrying a child yes okay and what does
she make about 46 okay of the of the 105
you said right okay so you make like 65
okay are 60 okay okay well I mean I I
don't tell people to not have kids
because of that I don't do okay I don't
think you've anything to be terrified of
here and I wouldn't say oh don't do it I
think you're crazy
you know I'm not going to say that
because I don't believe that in this
situation I think because of the health
concerns she could end up not missing
eight weeks of work with a normal labor
and delivery she could end up missing
nine months of work right because she
might have to you know I don't know have
some kind of a situation where she's not
working because of health with the
pregnancy to protect the baby so what
happened what happened my child our
first child she went on she had to go on
permanent bed rest at two months yeah
so she missed seven months of work plus
two after delivery so she went nine
months of work okay yes I mean that's a
valid concern that's a long time in your
old situation
do I want to wait a full two years
before I start that process no probably
not but I might want to make a little
more progress if I were in your hand
but I'm not saying you have to do that
understand you you have properly
analyzed and said hey there's a
mathematical risk here that we're facing
because you're probably not going to
make a ton of progress on your
financials if she's bedroom bed rest
right you're probably going to tread
water during that time and so you're
kind of putting all this on hold so I
don't again I might like to say if I
wanted to get rid of like half of this
and then we'll do it you know like maybe
sometime next year but just because I'd
want a little bit more of this behind me
get a little more the strain off the
family probably but I don't I don't
think it's like oh you're going to go
bankrupt your this is screwed up no it's
just how quickly and I'm just kind of
weighing out it's just the speed at
which you get out of that right and you
bring your current child's ages what six
six okay okay all right so it's not like
we've got a two-year-old we want to make
sure they're close together or something
right it's been a while okay because of
the fear of the pregnancy yeah yeah but
I mean what I permanently not do it no I
think you need to have another child if
you don't have another child I'm in with
that I love babies I think they're
awesome
I got grandbabies and if I don't know
how great grandbabies are going to be
I'd have been nicer to their parents I
mean it's it's it's a wonderful thing
so yes have a baby the only question is
whether they'll have it now or have it
when you get halfway through this desk
ball or weight all the way through which
might be a little bit of an extreme then
at that point you got an 8 year old nine
year old before the baby comes and so
you know you do what you want to do in
there but I don't want to have fear to
the point of saying don't do this it's
just a matter of if you do it as you
have correctly analyzed you're going to
have some delays in your debt snowball
process and that's fine that's okay hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]